bonjour berger merci beaucoup à vous
notre invité ce matin d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes député des
yvelines présidente déléguée du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview avec la
presse quotidienne régionale représenté
par julien lécuyer de la voix du nord
bonjour julien bonjour oriane bonjour
m'héberger bonjour roberge et on va
commencer en parlant de la crise des
sous-marins la crise qui se poursuit on
a entendu jean yves le drian s'exprimer
hier soir on entendu des voix de l'union
européenne également s'exprimer pour
soutenir la france où cela van der leyen
charles michel pourquoi emmanuel macron
ne s'exprime pas lui
déjà c'était important et vous le
soulignez que l'union européenne
s'expriment d'une même voix sur le sujet
parce qu'il ya une rupture de confiance
évidente avec un allié en alliés qui
était stratégique et qui est toujours un
allié stratégique pour la france cette
rupture de confiance elle nécessite
justement que l'union européenne
s'expriment d'une même voix parce que
l'enjeu est d'ailleurs le président de
la république s'était exprimé et
quelques temps s'est exprimé sur l'otan
il avait eu des mots très forts ils
avaient parlé mort cérébrale de l'otan à
l'époque ça avait d'ailleurs suscité un
certain nombre de remarques va dire ça
comme une preuve de plus selon vous en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que le
constat il avait été dressée par le chef
de l'état de la difficulté
existantes au sein de l'otan mais
surtout de la nécessité du coup d'avoir
une stratégie européenne
et quand on parle de souveraineté la
souveraineté en terme de défense de
défense stratégique elle n'est pas
seulement française elle est européenne
et le fait que l'un l'union européenne
parlez vous que vous avez évoqué
s'exprime c'est essentiel chez de l'état
et s'exprimera au moment où il estimera
être au pansement que c'est pas est-ce
que c'est pas là la nommant jean yves le
drian l'a dit c'est un coup de poignard
pour la france est ce que le chef de
l'état n'a pas à prendre la parole
j'aime de l'état il s'exprime quand il
estime que c'est pertinent de le faire
et personne lui dicte son agenda je
crois que les propos qui ont été très
clairs à la fois de la ministre des
armées évidemment du mini affaires
étrangères ont été je crois suffisamment
entendu là où il devait l'être que ce
soit aux états unis en grande bretagne
en australie et encore une fois la
réaction qui a été celle de l'union
européenne je crois que celle ci elle
démontre aussi justement la capacité que
la france peut faire valoir dans le cas
de la présidence française de l'union
européenne qui va s'ouvrir la question
enfin d'avoir une unité en terme de
défense stricte à émerger est ce qu'on
doit alors rappelé des ambassadeurs on a
annulé un banquet alors tout ça paraît
quand même 10 sont des sanctions ou une
réaction en tout cas un petit peu faible
et ce qu'il faut pas
je sais que c'est une première c'est une
première c'est inédit dans le langage
diplomatique en effet c'est un geste
fort malgré tout ce qu'il faut pas aller
plus loin et ce qu'il faut pas par
exemple se poser clairement la question
de notre présence au sein du
commandement intégré de l'otan et je
crois que la première question avant
celle ci est encore une fois je quand le
présent de la regione cas parler de mort
cérébrale de l'otan ce n'était pas des
mots tout à fait anodin c'est d'abord
comment on arrive à avoir nous mêmes une
souveraineté et une défense stratégique
qui est une défense européenne
ensuite la france elle a des alliés elle
a des alliés dans leur dos pacifique il
n'y a pas que l'australie et l'indonésie
est la langue est là le japon on a des
pays extrêmement puissant avec lesquels
on collabore vous avez vous aussi la
réaction du faux changent l'inde qui non
mais c'est pas changé de nom dit pas
qu'on tourne le dos à l'australie mais
on dit que l'australie elle s'ils sont
les mots du ministre aux affaires
étrangères nous a planté un poignard
dans l'eau le 30 août dernier encore le
30 août dernier il avait un communiqué
de presse conjoint de nos deux ministres
des affaires étrangères nos deux
ministres de la défense qui saluait le
contrat qui était en cours on était le
30 août donc ça veut dire qu'il n'y
avait pas de signes avant-coureurs
donner à la france une quelconque
manière d'une rupture de confiance et
que cela s'est organisée entre les états
unis et l'australie avec l'aval de la
grande bretagne et donc que ça encore
une fois on ne peut pas avoir ce genre
de comportement entre alliés quand on
est à lier il ya des manières de
travailler et s'il ya eu une rupture
nette claire de confiance analyse la
savonnerie aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus
des alliés fiables pour l'instant en
tout cas ils n'ont pas été montrés la
fiabilité qui était la leur et ça veut
dire aussi que la france qu'il ya
d'autres alliés dans la région la france
est une puissance y compris dans
l'hindou pacifique c'est ça qu'il faut
quand même avoir en tête c'est 1,6
millions de français qui sont présents
c'est la nouvelle calédonie donc c'est
un enjeu stratégique pour la france à la
fois de souveraineté de défense de
protection aussi tout simplement des
français qui sont installés et je crois
que ça doit être aussi une opportunité
encore une à la fois de retravailler ou
de travailler plus encore avec des
ailiers qui eux souhaitent ce
partenariat stratégique avec la france
l'un d'eux l'évoquait encore ces
dernières heures et puis enfin que
l'union européenne s'affirmant comme
ayant la capacité d'avoir une défense
vous soutiendrez madame énergie est-ce
que vous soutiendrez l'idée d'une
commission parlementaire sur le sujet je
suis pas certaine que la commission
parlementaire elles nous permettent
d'avoir des éléments jeudi le 30 août
s'il y avait encore ce communiqué de
presse donc je ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait
les moyens pour est très transparent et
honnête au parlement de savoir
clairement ce qui a motivé ou pas cette
décision qui s'est fait dans le dos de
la france en catimini avec dre santos la
demande des députés républicains bien
une petite dizaine de personnes qui a
été réellement informé de ce qui était
en train de se passer est que ces
personnes soient plus en australie et
aux etats unis je suis pas certaine
qu'ils puissent comparaître devant la
commission d' enquête parlementaire
qu'il faille auditionné le midi des
affaires étrangères il n'y est prêt la
ministre des armées évidemment les
ministres sont à la disposition du
parlement pour venir s'exprimer et
s'expliquer ils le feront je pense
qu'ils seront d'ailleurs dire soumis à
la question aujourd'hui même à
l'assemblée nationale on va parler d'un
autre sujet jeune et on va parler de la
crise sanitaire oui crise sanitaire
parce qu'on on avait cru comprendre que
les règles du pasa littérale et
pourraient être allégées et puis là le
gouvernement évoque une prorogation de
du pass sanitaire de la loi l'autorisant
en tout cas au delà du 15 novembre
alors on a du mal à comprendre et c'est
vrai qu on a presque l'impression qu'on
manie le chaud et le froid avec aller
avec les français jusqu'où ça va aller 7
cette histoire de pas sanitaires mais
jusqu'à ce que la france puisse sortir
de la crise sanitaire je crois qu'il
faut être très clair là dessus c'est à
dire que le pass sanitaires c'est la
capacité qu'on a à retrouver justement
des libertés qu'on croyait un temps
perdus du fait de la pandémie
dans le chef de l'état dire que le
règles pourraient être allégées
notamment le passé ni terre dans les
départements le virus circule mois hier
on apprend qu'un projet de loi va être
déposé pour prolonger l'opa sanitaire
c'est quand même toujours flair mais ce
qui est clair c'est quoi c'est que la
pandémie elle n'est pas finie c'est que
la quatrième vague elle est
malheureusement en cours de déploiement
et qu'elle a réussi en tout cas on dit
tout sur place olivier ferrand de vie
que c'est un ressenti mais en métropole
à être largement contenu pourquoi elle
était contenu parce que la dynamique de
vaccination s'est considérablement
amplifié et pourquoi elle s'est
amplifiée lorsqu'il ya eu les propos du
président de la république cet été et la
mise en place du pass sanitaires sans
passé ni tard vraisemblablement nous
n'aurions pas autant de français
vaccinés que ce qu'il en fait donc
certains l'ont fait par choix parce
qu'ils étaient convaincus de la
nécessité de se faire vacciner d'autres
l'ont fait parce qu'ils ont considéré qu
encore une fois
il fallait passer on entend cette
stratégie mais est ce que vous comprenez
les français qui ont l'impression de
vivre dans un état d'urgence permanent
et la question se pose d'autant plus
avec cette loi de provocation puisque en
fait on ne sait absolument pas quand
est-ce qu'elle va s'arrêter vous militez
pour pourquoi on se donne de la
perspective jusqu'à la fin de l'année
jusqu'à après les présidentielles les
législatives
on va jusqu'où la non mais déjà moi j'ai
pas eu communication aujourd'hui de ce
projet de loi dont comme en tant que
parlementaire pour l'instant je n'ai pas
eu à l'examiner j'ai même pas eu
communication de ce texte est-ce qu'il
faut potentiellement prorogé on l'a fait
en urgence début septembre pour un cas
spécifique et malheureusement les
antilles parce que la pandémie elle est
là bas loin loin mètres et tente
justement parce que la dynamique
vaccinale n'est pas suffisamment forte
ce que je crois c'est que tant qu'il y à
ce risque de pandémie tant que nous
sommes en pandémie comme nous le sommes
aujourd'hui veut dire tous les jours
mangé des mères qui m'appelle en disant
voilà j'ai une classe qui a dû
malheureusement fermé parce que on a un
cas contact des pharmaciens qui appelle
en dix ans on a une recrudescence
notamment deux tests positifs chez les
plus jeunes donc ça veut dire à la fois
qu'on a ce risque de variants donc de
mutation qu'on a encore une fois un
virus qui peut être de plus en plus
agressif avec d'autres types de
population qui aujourd'hui sont moins
vacciner que d'autres ce qui est certain
c'est que la france elle a réussi la
course contre la montre sur la
vaccination quand une fois au moins
métropole et juste sanitaire je reprends
la question du bien parce que le
parlement ne va pas siéger de mars à
juin pour cause de présidentielle et des
législatives est-ce que du coup il faut
dès maintenant prolonger le passé
l'hiver jusqu'à présent jusque là jamais
projet le passé ni terre on n'a jamais
mis en place pendant une durée d'un an
par exemple on a toujours fait en sorte
justement ne pas donner le sentiment
qu'on était en état d'urgence sanitaire
permanente par contre est ce que
aujourd'hui on l'est encore oui est-ce
que par endroits l'esquissé pas fixer
des seuils précis pour aussi laissé
comprendre aux français à quel moment
ils vont pouvoir espérer voir alléger
les contraintes aujourd'hui c'est quoi
les contraintes fin je pense qu'il faut
quand même là dessus être raisonnable
sur les contraintes qui sont demandés
aux français est ce que c'est
l'empêchement d'aller travailler nous
est ce que c'est la possibilité que vos
enfants aillent à l'école oui donc on
part quand même d'une situation qui a
été une situation initiale très dur de
confinement est s'il n'avait pas d'autre
choix ou on incitait très largement
voire n'obligeait au télétravail où les
écoles étaient fermées on a fait quoi
tout de suite après on a fait en sorte
que les écoles restent ouvertes et le
son on a fait en sorte que les personnes
progression puisse retourner travailler
aujourd'hui le ps à noter vous en avez
besoin dans un certain nombre
d'activités qui se limite quand même
quand même à présenter un qr code pour
avoir le droit me suis fait hier soir
dans les rues concerts d'aller au
théâtre d'aller au resto invités pré sal
invite le précédent pire leur ont
demandé un bilan avant de pouvoir
imaginer proroger cette fois sur le
sanitaire
nécessaire écoutez si les parlementaires
ça veut dire que dans un mois il ya plus
de pandémie ils sont très forts moi je
sais pas
demandez bien sûr quel a été le bilan de
cette christianisme plus ou moins la
logique unir un bilan d'une loi avant de
la proroger vous êtes d'accord sur ce
que vous voyez bien qu'on est quand même
sur loing qui est une matière un peu
différente d'une loi de finances ou
d'une règle fiscale qu'on met en place
là la question c'est parce que ça la
règle fiscale a rapporté plus ou moins à
l'état et donc à ce qu'elle est
efficiente là la question c'est est-ce
que oui ou non le passé ni terre
continue de protéger les français ben
réponse est oui parce qu'il continue à
accélérer lundi mick de vaccination qui
est le seul levier que l'on est pour
justement définitivement sortir et donc
supprimer lever les contraintes et donc
à terme supprimer justement puisqu'on
parle de la dynamique de vaccination
dernière question là dessus les
sénateurs socialistes ils ont déposé une
proposition de loi pour rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour tous le
débat aura lieu au sénat mais octobre
est ce que vous êtes favorable cette
obligation vaccinale pour moi j'ai
toujours été défavorable à cette
obligation parce que je ne vois pas le
caractère opérationnel de cette
obligation demain concrètement ça veut
dire quoi une obligation vaccinale ça
vous faites des contrôles aléatoires
dans la rue ça veut dire que vous
obliger les personnes à être isolé
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre
chez elles si elles ne veulent pas levé
être vaccinés alors même que le conseil
constitutionnel a refusé d'ailleurs que
de telles mesures puissent être prises
je ne vois pas les contraintes qui
pèserait sur celles et ceux qui ne
voudraient pas être vaccinés je le vois
dans le cadre du pass sanitaire le pass
anita si vous n'êtes pas vacciné il ya
des accès auxquels vous n'avez pas dans
ce que ces pannes à la règle des
obligations déguisée ce cas pas une
forme numérisée dans le panier peau
crise ces deux fêtes faire peser une
contrainte plus forte sur ceux qui ne
sont pas vaccinés plutôt que sur ce
qu'ils sont ce qui est quand même assez
légitime de se dire que si vous êtes
vacciné vous avez plus facilement en
effet lacoste et de recouvrer des
libertés par rapport à ceux qui ne le
sont pas et qui donc encore une fois
peuvent contaminer un certain nombre de
français alors autre actualité qui est
un anniversaire un triste anniversaire
il ya vingt ans exactement l'explosion
d'un stock de 300 tonnes de nitrate
d'ammonium dans l'usiné azf de toulouse
causé la mort de trente et une personnes
est ce que on peut se dire que toutes
les leçons ont été tirées de ceux de ce
drame et qu' il ne pourrait plus se
reproduire à l'heure actuelle on a
malheureusement eu un autre choc de ce
type de chopper industriel incendie de
lubrizol part exactement c'est à ça que
je pensais donc je peux pas répondre par
l'affirmative en vous disant que
malheureusement plus aucun accident
industriel ne peut exister est ce que
les normes ont été renforcées et normal
sont extrêmement exigeante et sévère à
la fois sur l'installation de nouveaux
sites industriels elles ont été
largement renforcées sur les contrôles
qui doivent pouvoir exister donc ça
c'est une certitude je crois qu'en
france on a un niveau de protection
justement de nos salariés qui est
extrêmement ils sont et c'est bien
légitime après personne ne pourrait
s'engager à vos réponses qu'on a été
suffisamment loin j'entends par là que
un rapport parlementaire avait été
effectuée juste après lui brise hall
donc et il semble que les moyens
d'alerté la population sont encore loin
d'être à la mesure des enjeux
concrètement est ce qu'il n'ya pas là
encore du travail à réaliser peut-être
qu'il ya encore du travail à réaliser en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est qu'il
faut systématiquement qui a une totale
transparence sur les risques qui
seraient potentiellement encourus par
les personnes vivant à proximité
et si jamais on avait à nouveau ce type
d'accident industriel mais encore une
fois on est en paix justement qui est
dotée d'arsenal à la fois juridiques
judiciaires parlementaire de contrôle
administratif qui font qu'ils concourent
à ce qu'ils aient une totale
transparence qui puisse exister et on va
parler du texte examiné par les députés
pour cette rentrée parlementaire oui
c'est l'actualité du jour pour la grande
rentrée des départs des parlementaires
l'assemblée son père du projet de loi
sur la responsabilité pénale et la
sécurité intérieure un texte a été voulu
par emmanuel macron suite à la décision
de la cour de cassation de déclarer
irresponsable l'homme accusé du meurtre
de sarah halimi
alors il ya des modifications qui sont
assez et qui sont assez substantiel
parce que s'aviserait finalement à
modifier la notion de responsabilité
pénale quand une quand on a affaire à
quelqu'un qui a acquis un gros
consommateur de drogue est ce que il
n'ya pas le risque de légiférer sous le
coup de l'émotion mais l'émotion est là
était justifiée l'émotion elle a été
justifiée par un mart est un meurtre
antisémite qui a conduit malheureusement
à ce que sont meurtris puisque personne
ne doute du fait que c'est bien lui qui
l'a assassiné et bien et était jugée
comme étant irresponsable parce qu'il
avait pris des substances qui
prétendument le rendaient responsable
la question qui est posée en droit et
que nous on pose en tant que
parlementaire c est ce qu à partir du
moment où délibérément vous prenez des
substances dont vous savez qu'elles vont
complètement obscurcir votre jugement
qu'elles vont pouvoir entraîné un
dérèglement psychologique est-ce que
c'est légitime que se serve d'argument
pour qu'ensuite vous ne puissiez pas
être reconnus comme étant responsable
pénalement et cette émotion qui a été
suscitée suite à la décision rendue il a
été suscitée non pas seulement dans la
communauté juive mais l'été suscité dans
l'ensemble de la communauté nationale
parce qu'il ya une incompréhension
manifeste mais quand il ya une
incompréhension manifeste c'est tout
simplement aussi peut-être parce que le
droit est mal écrit oui mal écrits ou
bien est-ce que s'il n'existe pas aussi
dans le droit à l'heure actuelle c'est
tout parce que ça montre la difficulté
pour caractériser cette notion de prise
volontaire je sais que des voix
s'élèvent même au sein de votre groupe
pour pour laisser entendre cette idée
est ce que on rajoute pas une un article
de loi qui va complexifier qui
finalement va être très difficile à
appliquer pratiquement sauf
qu'aujourd'hui pratiquement vous avez un
vide juridique et un vide juridique et
conduit à ce qu'un l'assassin ne soit
pas jugé comme étant responsable
pénalement d'un crime antisémite odieux
qui a été perpétré sur notre sol en
france donc pour vous est totalement
justifiée et pour moi c'est totalement
justifié j'attendais que ce texte puisse
arriver à l'assemblée nationale je serai
fier de le voter et encore une fois je
j'entends tout à fait la remarque est de
dire on peut pas légiférer
systématiquement aux modifier en
permanence notre droit parce qu'il y
aurait tel ou tel fai qui le
justifieraient ou qui créerait de
l'émotion sauf qu'ici on a envie de
juridique et c'est notre responsabilité
parlementaires et politiques de dire est
ce que oui ou non on considère que le
droit encore une fois est bien écrit ou
pas en l'espèce il ne l'est pas il ne
l'est pas suffisamment et il laisse une
forme de liberté d'appréciation qui est
trop importante et d'ailleurs c'est
souvent à cela que nous invite soit le
conseil d'état soit la cour de cassation
soit le conseil consiel en dix ans en
vérité là aujourd'hui à droit constant
voilà ce qui se passe c'est à vous de
prendre vos responsabilités politiques
et c'est ce qu'on fait avec ce texte on
va parler des dernières annonces des
manuels ma couenne dure gouvernement
alors beaucoup d'annoncés beaucoup de
dépenses ont souligné certains
commentateurs et certains opposants au
président de la république alors je
rappelle que et xavier bertrand par
exemple a
accusé le président de faire campagne
avec le chéquier d'aidé français
pourquoi il dit ça parce que en fait si
on comptabilise toutes les dépenses
toutes les promesses de dépenses
annoncées par le président depuis deux
semaines on atteint plus de 5 milliards
5,6 milliards d'euros est ce que on fait
pas campagne avec le ch et de piquer des
français on fait surtout campagne pour
protéger les français et au delà de
faire campagne on gouverne et nous
aujourd'hui on responsabilités on a eu à
la fois un moment d'urgence un moment
d'urgence dans lequel on a mis en place
l'activité partielle fonds solidarité
pour les entreprises et on a été en
soutien et si on a eu moins de
défaillances d'entreprises monde fei
d'entreprise en 2019 en 2020 barre donc
en 2019 c'est justement parce qu'on a
été en soutien et puis on a eu un plan
de relance parce que notre enjeu c'était
de faire repartir et repartir le plus
vite possible l'économie français mais
madame berger le 6 % de toute chasse à
100 francs on entend mais c'est bruno le
maire et le président de la république
qui ont dit eux même que le quoi qu'il
en coûte aller progressivement
s'éteindre et c'est à ce moment là en
même temps qu'on voit surgir énormément
de promesses de dépenses est ce que vous
comprenez le hiatus mais encore une fois
vous aviez un plan de relance avec près
de 100 milliards d'euros qui ont été et
qui sont encore en cours de déploiement
à la fois sur les enjeux de transition
écologique d'industrialisation de
réindustrialiser la france moi ce qui
m'étonne c'est espèce de double discours
permanent qu'on a de la part de celles
et ceux qui le sont déjà et ouvertement
en campagne je regarde le projet qui a
été déposée par les républicains projets
des parlementaires aient l'air il n'y a
que de la dépense publique
supplémentaire et dans le même temps il
nous disait attention vous vous créez de
la dépense publique on nous parle de
souveraineté industrielle et de
réindustrialisation de la france mais il
ne faudrait pas qu'il ya un plan pour
gagner notre radio pas qu'il est son
prix la relique alizés il n'y a pas que
les saucisses et ses promesses de
dépenses la cour des comptes et le haut
conseil de la finance publique en
l'occurrence s'interroge alors je prends
par exemple et de charles de courson
vice présidents de cour des comptes qui
parle d' open bar et qui dit mais en
effet s'il ya des dépens à des promesses
de dépenses c'est parfait mais où sont
les recettes mais les recettes c'est
notamment plus de 6% de taux de
croissance qui existe dans notre pays
les recettes c'est qu'on a un taux de
chômage qui est aujourd'hui revenue au
niveau d'avant la crise
ce qui veut dire encore une fois des
recettes supplémentaires et des dépenses
en moins en vérité sociale qu'on aurait
dû faire si on n'avait pas été en
soutien des français à la fois des
cendres des salariés et les entreprises
pendant la crise c'est ça qu'on a
déployé je suis désolé mais moi je ne
vis damman qu'on ne peut pas avoir la
même dynamique de dépense publique que
celle qu'on a eue au coeur même de la
crise est ce que pour autant il faut du
jour au lendemain tout arrêté alors qu
on a encore des secteurs qui sont en
souffrance des secteurs qui ont besoin
d'accompagnement ou de pas non plus par
exemple comme le fait que xavier
bertrand alors même qu'il était ministre
de la santé pleurer sur l'hôpital public
mais refuser qu'on engage les dépenses
qui sont nécessaires pour continuer à la
modernisation et à la revalorisation des
métiers qui sont ceux aujourd'hui de
l'hôpital donc il faut faire des choix
les choix politiques et puis un moment
il ya une élection et c'est les français
qui se trouveront sur la responsabilité
qui a été la nôtre pendant la crise et
werner question j'ai justement moi je
peux vous poser la question est ce qu'il
ne serait pas tant que pour vous que le
président de la république clarifie sa
situation certains encore une fois au
sein de 2 et les roms ce disque attendre
le dernier moment n'est pas forcément la
meilleure des stratégies pour vous est
ce qu'il doit se déclarer bientôt mais
il se déclara s'il le souhaite enfin moi
est ce que je souhaite que
clairement oui mais pour l'instant on
connaît on connaît beaucoup de
prétendants mais peu de candidats je
vois beaucoup de prétendants d'une
primaire candidats l'accord qui n'est
même pas encore vraiment une primaire et
cetera donc c'est bien et pour avoir
vécu les primaires malheureusement les
primaires en général c'est plutôt la
prime à la démagogie à l'outrance ni
d'ailleurs sur la dépense publique cotée
à l'air à mon agent pour en reparler et
on pourra faire les comptes aussi avec
la calculatrice à la fin si on l'avait
fondre à la question n'est pas de
répondre à la question est ce que moi je
souhaite que le président de la
république soit candidat oui est ce que
je serai la question a réélu se déclare
non est-ce qu'ils aient l'obligation de
se déclarer dès maintenant au regard de
la situation regarder les sujets sur
lesquels vous m'avez interrogé sujets
sur lesquels on m'avait interrogé c'est
sur la question de la crise sanitaire et
du pass and it donc c'est parfait mais
moi je crois qui a pas d'urgence est la
déclaration de candidature et je crois
d'ailleurs qui a presque même une
lassitude des français à ne parler que
de la campagne présidentielle alors que
leur quotidien il est fait de bien
d'autres choses que des primaires
écologistes ps où l air ou même de la
déclaration du président de la
république merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin merci julien
regarde la une de la voix du nord c'est
du foot à la une de la voix du nord
premières sanctions qui sont tombés et
des aires de lavalle plus bel aspect du
foot disons blue mais après les
incidents lors du derby lens lille merci
je vais bien merci aurore bergé
[Musique]